join the dots
it's happening it's happening in your
world it's happening in my world
a plea to global leaders to deliver
ambitious
new promises to save the planet the
virtual climate ambition summit signals
the starting gun
on 12 months of intensive diplomacy
ahead of next year's landmark cop 26
climate conference
hosted by the uk we're doing this
not because we're hair shirt wearing
tree hugging mung bean munching eco
freaks so i've got nothing against any
of those
uh categories and mung beans are
probably delicious we're doing it
because we know that scientific advances
will allow us collectively as humanity
to save our planet and create
millions of high-skilled jobs britain
has already pledged
to cut its emissions by 68 by
2030 compared to 1990 levels
now it's encouraging others to follow
suit
mountains and rivers green are mountains
of silver
and gold one by one dozens of leaders
came forward to outline
new climate commitments to all my fellow
residents of this planet
i make a solemn place today
centennial india will not only meet its
own targets
but will also exceed your expectations
from renewables in india to ending new
coal
power plants in pakistan even the pope
made a video contribution
the vatican city has committed to
reducing net emissions to zero
by 2050 stepping up efforts in
environmental management that were
launched a few years ago
in 2015 in paris countries agreed to try
to limit
global warming to 1.5 degrees above
pre-industrial levels five years on
countries like australia which has
experienced searing temperatures and
bushfires
were noticeably absent from the list of
speakers
it's the club that everyone is in and
the beauty of the paris agreement is it
encourages everybody to set plans each
one more ambitious than the last so that
we can achieve
our climate goals but still there are
countries who are not really waving the
membership flag very well at the moment
aren't there well today is about
showcasing best practice and we hope
that
other countries will sit up and take
notice and accept the challenge
small island states on the front line of
climate change like barbados
and the maldives are pledging to be
carbon neutral within 10 years
hoping to encourage the bigger
industrialized economies they can
and should travel faster to tackle
climate change lisa holland sky news